this show is brought to you by dr. Sara
go to DSG calm and check out their
extremely high-quality functional gear
made with hemp textiles they have bags
G's rash guards and much much more
including the famous fanny pack it's des
gear calm and use codeword Joey to get
5% off shows also brought to you by O
Netcom go to on a dog calm knees covered
church to save 10% on all the amazing
optimization products like alpha brain
new moods from to commune and shroom
tech support kick that mule Lee kick it
kick it I want you to blow my [ __ ]
speakers right out it's ruckus Sunday
night aka Monday morning [ __ ]
you
that
let's go to home aha Joey yeah
oh [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] great
jam and it's weird because you think is
that the one that no it's the other one
Black Betty you think it's the almond
rose black Betty's I used to I came on
the stage to Black Betty for [ __ ]
four year old that is such a gray hear
that and I get chills now who sings that
Ram Jam Ram Jam they're out of
Jacksonville or maybe they're not out of
Jacksonville but I was got that jet like
when you watch there the video there in
like in front of just an old redneck
two-story White House and just
bell-bottoms and [ __ ] 1970 real
simple song oh I [ __ ] love red bag I
love like that whole [ __ ] what's going
on Bert Kreischer
I say yeah so good I'm so happy to be
here how long have you been hold for
you've been home for a [ __ ] while
yeah I bet I'll be home for a little
longer too now that they canceled that
talk the how many weeks where you want
it I was just doing two but I pulled out
you know I don't do cuz we talked about
this but I'm too much as much on the
ropes had the girls and so I pulled the
two weeks I was working and I filled him
up with that tour and so the other weeks
I had off so soon as I tore one away I
couldn't recall those weeks now what
were the other weeks you bubble you date
you had on the HOD I was doing in
Seattle Portland Red Rocks Red Rocks one
that bums me out so I really wanted to
do Red Rocks that's uh yeah but it would
have been Saturday when Red Rocks to
1,500 people yeah I was telling this is
what I was saying about a Joey you know
what it was the comic Center on it are
all fantastic comics but they're not you
know the people that go to that show are
comedy fans they're event comedy fans
like like Sebastian's of great comic and
comedy fans go see Sebastian but he's
not like a Sam Kinison Dave Chappelle
Mitch Hedberg like his life's really
nice and it's put together and he does a
really great act and what shocked me it
wasn't just Sebastian it was Gabriel it
was Segura was but there Jim Jefferies I
mean you have all these people and you
couldn't chop up the ticket I really
thought I had mixed feelings I thought
that listen let me tell you something
before I got into comedy I'm gonna taste
I'm right off the bat this is how I
don't commonly work
you went to the [ __ ] movies the movie
was sold out and you and your girlfriend
was sitting with your dick in your hand
you called the other movie theater that
sold out but you looked across the
street mrs. [ __ ] Connelly club and
you walk across the street and it's 20
bucks to get in a two-drink minimum you
go in there you don't know who the comic
is you laugh your [ __ ] ass off you
smoke cigarettes you know it's one of
those things it became a business metal
yeah like it's become a big-time
business now it's two drinks they want
to do four shows a night they want to do
all this stuff so now they got ticket
surcharges we're all three bucks on
every day and every [ __ ] ticket that
us as comedians don't see a dime of yeah
not a [ __ ] dime of and now you have
the ticket the tour was successful the
last couple of years but it also had
Chappelle and fly to the Concorde was
events it was Pearl Jam they had like
fight of the Conchords and Louie and Amy
and buzzy one time do you want me that
ISM that one time then I doubt the
comics that were on the tour this year I
did another room all of them just
Gabriel and some listen Sebastian did
seven nights at the [ __ ] theater in
New York that's theater with the horn
with the [ __ ] Allman Brothers playing
a role you know bill bird didn't know 19
[ __ ] sellouts in Boston yeah you know
Gabriel jesus [ __ ] christ where
doesn't he [ __ ] do by the prints
flies Herman you know these are great
comics in their own way the tops 107
dollars
Lisa T one on line for the $30 tickets
and there were two miles away you had a
binoculars and another binoculars and a
[ __ ] binoculars yeah you know I'm
saying so it's what I've been talking
about but I got a problem no no I talked
to Tommy Easter okay he said he went to
a Dodger game the other day for 18 bucks
right yeah now how the [ __ ] people tell
me at two hours the [ __ ] seats
how does Tommy used to go for 18 [ __ ]
dollars well it's it's the game time and
there's other ones like it but it's
that's all it is it's just uh I mean he
sat in hell he said yeah he's in hell do
you know they have a medical marijuana
smoking section that Dodgers know
no they don't yes they don't know
there's no there's no actually he told
me I'll call them right now are you
serious yeah if they have a smoking
section
and a medical I mean you gotta walk
eight miles by the time you get the
healing we might as well leave we're by
the bus station you know we're all away
focus over Lake yeah was silver like
already so I heard there's a medical
marijuana [ __ ] little smoke bad dad
listen you're gonna spark about a
[ __ ] game anyway there's nothing more
you would be too nervous at a baseball
game are you [ __ ] kidding me that's a
home with Sparkle a joy Mangano Yankee
game one time and looking down and
seeing crack vials yeah in 1993 holy
[ __ ] Tim I need a little crack vials and
[ __ ] Yankee Stadium people sitting
there with a cigarette you don't know it
you don't smoke crack you smell
something be your song Rawls in the game
you probably think it's popcorn you know
I would hate to go to a game of my
daughter with your daughters and I have
to go daddy what's that smell yeah and
follow me I wouldn't hate to do it so I
think that it's better just give them
listen it's legal it's might as well be
legal here
might as well be legal here people smell
it now and they go goddamnit
they go what the [ __ ] but here's that
here's my question but going back to the
tour is I think two things I think
people were really regret not having
bought those tickets in two years but it
but I think that like everyone that was
on the tour there was no like Louie or
Chappell or like like just someone like
Louis Chapelle or great white sharks
like when they walk into a club even we
get like foxy Chappelle's here you know
or like and like when Sebastian walks
into it I'm not [ __ ] on Sebastian I
love Sebastian but when he walks in the
club oh cool Sebastian's here I get to
see him I think he's [ __ ] brilliant
but it's not like the you know the
Chappell or Louie or the the almost like
they have that LeBron status we're like
I don't even give a [ __ ] about
basketball but I do want to see LeBron
play against where he does at the same
time Amy Schumer's not so know so
Aidan's got that status is she's not
young he's got that stat he's not
selling tickets right now know that I
ever find amphitheater ran a [ __ ]
group on two Saturdays ago
really one is the one they're really
embarrassed about that's the one that's
eaten away at them they're not even
selling tickets to Irvine well here's
the thing I went to Irvine a couple
years ago and I don't know any of the
comics personally but it wasn't it was
one of those event shows as you said it
was the bigger names was your pal
no no not even dude was a year after
that it was like it was no I I was on
the total disease but it was easy I had
a gaff again and Louie CK and all that
stuff and I think Joey what you were
saying I think you're absolutely right I
think if like the tour that was on this
oddball tour was at the store one night
or at the Irvine improv whatever
something like that that would be any we
just went in there as a monster you know
the best show of your life this was a
better show a hundred and five dollars
for a show yeah I told you since day one
on the drive to [ __ ] Indianapolis
listen I knew Indianapolis wasn't gonna
sell yeah I just knew it as soon as I
saw Sunday I go I'll get a ticket but
this is the Bible Belt
yeah and it's a zombie that's I don't
think it's gonna sell that's the first
thing that went down that was made me
[ __ ] this static yes now I got
Thursday Friday Saturday you know the
long drive is Atlanta they make all this
to say Atlanta was going down and we're
like what the [ __ ] we and that night I
was at the ice house and I was talking
to one of the door guys and I go I'm
embarrassed for Gabriel Gabriel because
Gabriel still went to Fort Lauderdale
okay and it's still sold on VMworld at
$50 per ticket okay so don't [ __ ]
tell me
these [ __ ] looked at that
because though what do you go see
Gabriel by yourself no no you take your
wife
that's a yardstick that's a [ __ ] lie
stick the same yardstick you willing to
use for whatever the yardstick was there
I don't think I think that one they
called the service fees were high I was
like 130 a ticket I think there was a
lot of variables I think the other thing
was for me I think it was late in the
season I think it's late in the season
right now Bert Kreischer is not thinking
about anything right now in two or three
days both of your girls go to school
yeah you know that's what another fad
you know you who knows it's an election
year who the [ __ ] knows
yeah who the [ __ ] knows what I do know
is that what comedy club do you go to
the tempie now none none yeah even the
comedy store sells out on [ __ ]
Tuesday nights
you know flappers is doing great [ __ ]
the ice house is doing great comedies on
the way up so that's this is why this
whole tour is so very unexplainable it's
so very like wait a second what are we
doing wrong here so where who's so
where's the fault go like woo [ __ ] it
up nobody [ __ ] it up it's everybody's
fault it's not a comedians for no it's
not the comedian's marketing's for maybe
it's there's a lot of things that fall
care but you want me to tell you
something I think that uh people call
the comedy shows again people going to
comedy shows [ __ ] then I talk to
people all the time they go see me you
you know they go see segura they go see
Duncan they go see right four and eight
quickly it does what I think it is it
that's a lot of money let's just say
we're gonna get a $100 ticket look I'm
sure there's more there's less expensive
than that but for five then that means
you could gone and seen any of you guys
five times and seen an hour so do you
think do you think oh that's a good
point Lee so so theoretically if I'm
understand what you're saying when they
first did this tour the people were
again like comedy was on the right
upswing with her like shut up comedies
great again oh [ __ ] I can see everyone I
want to see in one night as opposed to
now comedies in the upswing it's doing
well and now everyone's like [ __ ] that
I'm gonna save all these dollars and see
each of these guys do an hour it's
almost like a more comedy savvy crowds
or like I'd rather go see Joey for 30
bird for 30 Gabe for 50 you know what I
mean and see them do an hour as opposed
to you gonna do going in 15 up front
birth to 10 Tom Segura do 12 Eliza do 15
you know what I mean not because of my
logic that I explained to you but I've
always thought movies
I beg the agents to keep the ticket to
25 hours I'll keep my monocle on then
one day I go to I keep day oh you should
know 27 on Thursday 20 it's [ __ ] date
night it's single my point yeah you know
agent to push you to no end no [ __ ]
in with numbers guys I just want you to
know that at home you know when I go on
stage I gotta be honest with you this is
why I don't bring anything on the road
because I just want to worry about
company yeah I don't want to worry about
door deals ticket prices none of that
[ __ ] I don't want the people to get
gouged you know Thursday night 15 bucks
if you can 22 but then I find out a week
later this is eight dollar service
charge yeah two dollars if you will call
the tickets it's a [ __ ] nightmare you
know yeah you never stop getting [ __ ]
you know the thing that hurt me the most
I have these flight plane tickets I got
they all had a cancellation fee 150 $200
I caught three [ __ ] different times
and they gave me two breaks eventually I
knew they were gonna say Joey we gotta
charge you with swapping some Southwest
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah I was taking
the Southwest from Tampa to Atlanta they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah they just said
we'll put it on your tab virgin made me
open up a bank account a sky bank and
put my money in there and I got a year
to use it just it's [ __ ] [ __ ] for
anyway beside that was going on we say
you had a wonderful weekend yeah and San
Diego you went to see Lee had a little
problem we had a little [ __ ] problem
this week that I didn't think about till
you said something and then it made a
lot of sense because a Napa sir and
everybody in this room right couldn't
get it up well that happened before but
that wasn't this weekend what what is
the problem well I went to my girlfriend
got us tickets I like this EDM band and
I went I started seeing them when I was
18 and I've seen them probably over 15
20 times and we went down there and
within ten minutes we were both looking
at each other like this isn't an artist
like this like this wasn't her scene to
begin with she's just being a nice
person and going because I like it these
people it's people joy who I feel like
if you went in there it would be the
best YouTube video because it's
when doing drugs just to do drugs like
they have like they have the pacifier
they have these lighted finger gloves
that they were just doing in front of
someone's face as they were supposedly
tripping and I was I was on eight
hundred milligrams and I was laughing in
their in their face because they were
doing like little light fingers and but
basically my problem I told you the next
morning I don't know if it's age or
maybe I just grew outgrew it I still
like I'll listen to them in the car and
I like going if there's like a an up
like I saw them in LA and I could sit
down and really watch the light show and
that was cool but to be in a pit and
like it when you say jumping up and down
doing all that stuff we left after 15
minutes one got Mexican food and went
going home no that was our night like it
was just it was uh we went down there
for that and the highlight of the trip
by far was the San Diego Zoo
Javier's who's pretty [ __ ] badass oh
yeah it's great and like pretty [ __ ]
badass and we were like there are kids
there and we were having a better time
than the kids we were taking pictures
there's pandas we went and saw the
monkeys now that would be a fun place to
get to take these mushroom chocolates I
think or something the condors pretty
[ __ ] badass at the San Diego Zoo I
didn't see the condors [ __ ] insane
insane you're like that looks like it's
it's not even a real animal just like
like I want to say they're a 12-foot
wingspan just like a [ __ ] Derrida
it's insane Thursday I went to the LA
Zoo what a dump
what a [ __ ] dump Heather's what a
dump
it looks like those animals got hit by a
car they look like a rescue and oh my
god the [ __ ] Apes are they really
terrible the [ __ ] alligator had a
fungi toenail like I do
it was [ __ ] green and purple I mean
the snakes are nice the kid has a great
time it's a great little exercise for
now when I have yeah it's all uphill but
it's not one of my favorite [ __ ] I'll
tell you I think it was fun we spent the
night at the San Diego Zoo I saw that
you could do that I was [ __ ] Isla for
her birthday found out that you could do
that she's like that's what I want to do
Joey you hear the lions roaring at night
just it's follow the rules it's in was
that how the rooms it's like it's like
cabins like tents in suspense you
I like like cabin tents tent cabins it's
a tent is they usually pit in the [ __ ]
zoo and you and you do like a night walk
around the zoo so you go out at night
it's so [ __ ] bad and they leave when
animal sounds they're a [ __ ] fence
around you yeah you wouldn't do that joy
one of those like far asleep falsely
Joey's store in the [ __ ] the
elephant's trying to match him
oh I couldn't [ __ ] sleep just knowing
that there are friends away oh it's so
crazy it's the same now I mean it's the
same I don't what do we have between the
street and you do we spent the night I
spent the night in right on the inn in
Tanzania we were in Tanzania going into
the refuse to do a safari and we spent
the night right on the on the lip of it
and it was so cool and you could hear
lions at night and it was just and you
knew they could walk up and just walk
into your front door they could be there
you could open the door and a lion could
be there and used to herd them [ __ ]
roaring in the middle of the night the
hyenas going [ __ ] nuts that [ __ ]
that's insane to me like the fact that
like you could walk outside and a lion
could just grab you [ __ ] that no I like
animals but I don't wanna get grabbed by
mistake by nobody that I spent a night
at the [ __ ] thing in the tent that's
the night the Mexican ground keep a
drink tequila he didn't put a lock on
the [ __ ] gate that's the same way
yeah and I gotta wake up next to Tim
below I and I can't do timber have you
ever done the ones Burt like I don't
even know where they have the more you
can like drive through and there's
animals around oh oh yeah yeah whatever
the [ __ ] they do in Jersey add that will
you drive with the window a little hope
no no no window open no no it maybe you
can but I'm not opening the window here
let me show you I'll show you a picture
of how close I was to a lion we did it
cuz we did it within an open-air tent
and just drove all over the [ __ ]
literally into the jungle and there's a
lion not even [ __ ] you probably as
far as me from that that that uh flag
probably double that but he's just
sitting there in its open areas just
sitting there staring at you thumb like
tail slap it on the ground just like a
[ __ ] cat no no you can't do it right
no I don't think so I'll show you I'll
show you a picture it'll like it was
[ __ ] insane I don't like when there's
like a stray dog on my street it freaks
me out a little bit I get [ __ ] up
unless you're pigeon but I know the
pigeons in my neighborhood they're all
[ __ ] up I see a pigeon from outside of
different neighbors I get all nervous
should I well I mean cuz you Joey you
don't go to concerts anymore there's
going back to what happened at my
concert well it's interesting that you
said it to me it's interesting that you
cop to it a lot of people couldn't cop
to it I I don't know I went to I used to
go to concerts to see different bands
and I I'm not gonna lie nobody they
would never like bar bands at that age I
would just go see the bands at the
garden nor then they're so Coliseum or
the places like that
I think once I turned about the wedding
was when I would get to a concert and
ask myself like once they played the
song I wanted to him I got it yeah yeah
I left people like Judas Priest I let
people at concerts but my biggest ever
was when I left Dan myrrh at the Rolling
Stones at the Hollywood ball Dan listen
who walks out a [ __ ] like 10th row
seat tickets and just walks home after
three songs yeah like that's the [ __ ]
that I was working my cell phone that's
why the last year and a half I've been
gone to a UFC with Joe yeah because I'm
to the point where I can't sit there no
more I can't sit down no more and it
started when I was 20 places I'm going
to see you know what continent I enjoy
it like Don Henley and filled his green
and 95 that was one concert I enjoyed
because was easy drive it was an easy
walk but now it seems like they just put
much [ __ ] drama well you always say
something to me every time I go I'm
going anywhere you're just tell me to
download the album do you have a joint
you're like gonna go down there you said
it to me I went to the Rams game [ __ ]
you go to the Rams game and there was a
fight that night yeah there was a fight
you know you take your wife what if they
took the girls we got season tickets
yeah you're another one that's half
[ __ ] I get season tickets to go down
there to get beat up
it was [ __ ] crazy it was a lot the
bells down there what everyone was
speaking Spanish behind us it's these
sporting events now and they're all one
of them bad yeah that's the thing that
you you know is having it's like you sit
there and go when is something gonna go
down at one of these [ __ ] things you
can feel it you can feel it going on
behind us I feel that energy was like
man energy and I could and I was it was
like third quarter and I was like let's
get the [ __ ] out I was like it's a night
game the day games will be better this
is a night game it's a preseason night
game so it's all the riffraff and the
guys behind us we're talking [ __ ] in
Spanish and I could understand a little
bit what they were saying and I was like
man if this was English literally Liane
would be turned around going shut the
[ __ ] up and I was and then these and
then they were sitting in these other
guys seats and the other guys came up
finally but I pulled the car and they
were like listen you need to get the
[ __ ] up you're sitting in our seats and
the guy was like are we gonna do this
and I was like all right let's go what
the [ __ ] are we doing listen man I went
to 7-Eleven the end and I'm sitting
there minding my business it is this guy
who gets whatever cigarettes Newports
he's Mexican he's got a raid at that too
on his own and then in her tattoo on his
side like he's got that helmets on his
head
but here's what it gets even beauty on
his head it celebrators and I'm looking
at this guy and I'm like that's who
Bert's and I said at that [ __ ] game I
mean and that Judge in your body but you
know
I just like can't and therefore one
point you're like Joey you're very
negative because you look at the outcome
you think about the moves okay I'm gonna
go down there first of all it's [ __ ]
forty five [ __ ] minutes
and these jamokes aren't used to going
into a stadium coming out of the stadium
yeah so that's an extra [ __ ] forty
two minutes to go in then I'm gonna walk
up then I'm gonna sit next to [ __ ] you
know God knows who
because these people have been waiting
for the [ __ ] Rams I would've gave up
after three years yeah I'm done
I'll go [ __ ] watch ping pong on
DirecTV or something
yeah and then you know that we're
talking about today are there
gentrifying that area and then do I mean
they closed the Hollywood Bowl because
it was so [ __ ] bad that's the
Hollywood Bowl the Hollywood track what
was that's where they're putting the
[ __ ] stevie they're going from one
bad yeah this is not to love going to
that track on Friday nights Oh for the
dollar B dollar to get a hot dog dollar
hot dog you gotta walk to your car yeah
cuz you win twenty dollars that long
that's the longest walk ever you go not
celebrate your wins dog those are some
angry black people or that law outside
they just stare at you we you would die
I went to the casino once and how bad
was it they were they have a weird thing
in California where you can bet if the
dealer's gonna bust and people will come
in and place a bet on that if they don't
have enough money to place up like a bet
on a hand so this dude came by and I'm
used to playing in Vegas where that bet
doesn't exist and there's black dude it
just comes in places the bet guy he's
like that's my bet I'm like okay and
then I was playing two hands cuz I'm
crazy I'm one hand lost in one hand one
or something and he switched them who
tried to switch it and he's like he
tried to get mad at me and take the
money now there's like this is my clue
to leave like I parked when I got there
there's like a valet parking and there's
like a free parking I parked myself in
the valets products I just knew like I
was already that's where that's where
paula is from that's a girl I'm dating
she lived behind it so I would be I was
down there once a week it's not it's not
a great place like I don't know where
these people who are gonna go park down
there
and then stroll for a late-night Oh
after the game it's not gonna be good
you can't look you the truth is if you
want to see a Rams game you better go
now you're not gonna be able to afford
the new stadium new stadium the seats
licensing is gonna be 50 grand to see so
you're never gonna afford to be able to
get season tickets ever again so I was
like you know what [ __ ] it this is the
one time Oliver say I was a season
ticket holder to anything ever in my
[ __ ] life it was really cheap good
seats and I was like [ __ ] it we'll do it
but and then immediately I was like I
should have gotten two tickets the girls
will never want to go to another [ __ ]
game and it's and then in my head I was
like I was like you know and that but
this new this new seat Licensing thing
is gonna be 50 grand per seat and it'll
be an ownership of that seat everything
that won't even yeah and no one-time
payment okay so it's like buying a house
you're buying property you're buying
that property and you will own the right
to that seat in perpetuity and then you
can sell the right to your seat to
somebody or you can just get to get the
[ __ ] ticket by the way that doesn't
even count this the denim in season
tickets you gotta buy season tickets on
top of the seat licensing it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
so whatever take an investment it's an
investment but you gotta be rich as [ __ ]
to do I mean like you know I'll tell you
oh it's the stock market hit the seats
what you do is you buy the rights to the
[ __ ] seat then you buy season tickets
then you could sell them at eight times
the [ __ ] face value they don't give a
[ __ ] cause you paid that 54 that's
that's the thing is like you look at
like Denver when they did it it seemed
ridiculous and then now my buddy Paul
was like man I really really wish I had
just gotten a loan and done it because
they'd be invaluable to you can't you
there's a long long list assume a bowl
you said you got Vilas [ __ ] tuition
yeah
that's that's the reality that's the
reality cuz some dummy will go I won't
rip tickets no yeah you know some
celebrity I'm a TV show don't know no
better
never been to a [ __ ] guy a sporting
event doesn't nothing I'm asking for a
thousand pictures and [ __ ] he'll buy one
thousand things and then you do I don't
know guys I grew up in Shea Stadium
I grew up mess where God watching Nick
games and I have the last Laker game I
went to I paid
[ __ ] tickets just to go and I gotta
tell you something that I felt ripped
off
I just felt violated you know I used to
see on I used to go see great Nick teams
for 15 bucks 22 bucks yeah you know now
I'm paying 190 180 you know and it's not
about the [ __ ] digits it's it's the
principle it's the [ __ ] principle my
friend here close to Disneyland they
have that scale somebody was telling me
the idea to have some scale and
Disneyland no is this true
Oh a sliding scale for payment like
there's some days were it's more and
there's some days that it's less of
summer it's like a hundred bucks you
said that was a while ago I heard 100
bucks here under buns of a scale no like
a hundred bucks today he went he's like
one of the high days so it was a
collision some bucks oh so it's like a
perfect day to go and they jack up the
price of the prices sometimes they know
they can yeah there's something weird a
Disneyland like they do they have last
days last week a summer it is [ __ ]
slam packed it is really everyone wants
one hey one last trip to Disney go a lot
you gonna we've gotta look we've got a
bunch we've gotten a bunch we got we got
season passes to Knott's Berry Farm
which is I think better in my opinion
it's it doesn't have the it doesn't have
the like fanfare that that Disney has
like Disney has a little bit of a story
in back story and if you've seen the
movies you meet the princesses for a
little girl it's ultimate but the girls
are at an age now where they just want
to ride the rides and the rise of not
Burton awesome Berry Farms are so much
better and they serve booze I think
Disney does too but they serve booze and
the food is [ __ ] to do if the fried
chicken is the best fried chicken you've
ever had they've got these Knott's Berry
I mean the food is [ __ ] phenomenal
Knott's Berry Farm
really the rides are awesome especially
for little kids they got like a whole
section of rides for little kids that
you couldn't you couldn't even do all
the rides I'm not ready yet
yeah ha wait how old is how
three-and-a-half yeah I'm not ready in
front to see her on a ride swinging
around Georgia asked tonight she goes
whoa is he gonna be ours is he gonna be
at school Tyler and
like a she's too young she was like wait
how old is she George was trying to do
the math she was like okay I think she's
five dad and I was like she's not five
to what he's supposed to being four so
she'll go to whatever next year whatever
transition okay next year yeah starts at
95 goes to 119 and that's when it starts
at so on some days like middle of the
week you starts at 95 and on the
weekends it can start at 119 I mean okay
I'll tell you what one of the best trips
I ever had to Disney we went down there
and it was sold out it was packed and is
there like here when I saw the tickets
but the girls were so young they didn't
know the difference between Disney and
Disney like Disney walk you know if the
shops outside so we just took him to the
shops bought a couple nightgowns bottom
a [ __ ] princess had drinks at dinner
and drove Oh like we just did they were
like that's Disney more like yeah girls
enjoy that's it it's amazing the juggled
is dead [ __ ] godly [ __ ] I said to
Fitzsimmons the other day how do I
apologize it's [ __ ] amazing
I don't know how the [ __ ] I do it I
don't know how you could you do it the
way I do it like me and you were the
same Fitzsimmons that he was like he was
like I go how do you go do sets and then
wake up with the kids and he was like I
don't he said I sleep till 10:00 no one
bothers me that's I'm a dad and that's
my job is to work and that's my job is
to do sets and that's it I'm sure he
said it differently than that but that
was the job that was what I got out of
it but me and you are still juggling
like the go do sets come home get up at
6:00 in the morning and be awake get
everyone going then go back maybe I take
a nap for me at like noon but go work I
go work out I come I [ __ ] take
meetings do a podcast like it's I just
it's hard as [ __ ] man it really is I you
know it's like people go look at Louie's
trajectory of success I got to be honest
with you and I think Louie would say the
same thing he didn't start really
getting successful until he got out of
his marriage because in that marriage
would you have a person saying to you
hey hey you got you got to be
responsible for this and this and this
it's really
hard to justify doing a ten-minute spot
15-minute spot in the o.r and missing
dinner you know or missing or not being
available for dinner or knowing that you
won't get up for drop-off because you're
not gonna get home until 2:00 in the
morning or 1:00 in the morning you know
they see for me I was married and I
didn't give a [ __ ] I had no idea what
marriage was I have no idea what nothing
was I thought you went home woke your
wife up stabbed and then got up the next
morning and whatever I didn't know what
it was
I don't think Terry would never say
anything to me about my schedule
yeah I just decided the things I wanted
to do as a human being like I just
decided I go I'm gonna do this but this
is also what I have to do you know first
off if if they leave and I sit there on
the computer the whole time I'm thinking
about them she's driving on the school
like I'm having a bad feeling yeah you
know what I stopped you know what I just
go with them now yeah I get up attempt
when I go with them and then me my wife
go have coffee for 20 minutes somewhere
we talk about our day she splits I split
and that's the beginning of my [ __ ]
day yeah I think it's really important I
lived in this town for 14 years before
mercy came I took every [ __ ] stupid
jerk off meeting I've taken every
[ __ ] call I did everything one day
you start deciding what's important and
what's not important well have a youtube
project I want to talk to you about you
know sorry brother we can make millions
on the penny program that's great it's
not gonna [ __ ] happen in my world
yeah when do we shoot we shoot in
Calabasas mud niche it's not gonna
happen unless you should allow me were
they gonna have yeah like one day it
just snapped on me you know Lee and I
were doing the podcast in his house and
there was a run I had on the road which
it was eight weeks and then too often
another six
I remember that one in and and okay I
made some money but the numbers went
down the podcast I gained 30 pounds
because of lack of sleep you just gain
weight even if you stick to your diet
yelling what the [ __ ] going on yeah
I haven't destroyed the M&Ms in the
hotel room and I gained three [ __ ]
pounds you know and I figured out and I
was still putting the time at home and
it was really [ __ ] killing me like I
have a thing if I'm home I'm picking her
up and I'm dropping her off unless of
course you have an envelope yeah if you
have an envelope at 4:30 I will or that
means an audition that means anything of
that thing but if I'm gonna get an
envelope you're not gonna see me you're
not gonna see me at 5:30 people are
furious at me because that won't do that
podcast but they have a reasonable
podcast they want to tape at five
o'clock in Culver City you never gonna
see me oh I wish I could say no to those
in traffic no I have to I say I say yes
and then forget I said yes and then they
call up and like so we tape in Venice
yes seven and I'm like got the girl I
got the girls and I got dinner dinner
with my family is more important than a
[ __ ] podcast yeah you know that's how
I have to look at it that's how I have
to approach this [ __ ] if not I'm gonna
go on their own and make a little money
but I'm gonna lose that and what's the
sense in [ __ ] to do what anything if
I don't have them so no no no no so now
I'm trying to go two on and two off you
know Thursday do you think I really want
to go to LA [ __ ] Zoo no oh I have two
options to go to the LA Zoo meet the
rider
or go to jujitsu I had already been to
jujitsu twice and they [ __ ] killed me
in the advanced class
we couldn't even walk I went to the zoo
yeah everybody was happy what do we do
after the zoo in with the Morstan market
I became more one of those women that
puke after they bulimic that's what I am
every time I hang on my daughter because
she wants to go to Boston Market so I
got a bulimic that [ __ ] Turkey there
and the food's getting worse and worse
than they had chicken college the worst
things I ever tasted in my life yeah now
they had something last refill I tried
what the [ __ ] did I eat last week that
wasn't bad I mean it doesn't get me sick
the food so you don't really but my
daughter likes the mac and cheese from
there so if we're on that side of town
she says mac and cheese and me and my
wife would like she knows the size of
town
I shall know be like yeah okay okay
there's a Kenny Rogers over here any
Roger there all the time on Highland
yeah it's a little island that was the
filthiest Roger ever and every time you
wouldn't like Kenny Rogers you felt
worse and most about your life it was
down the block from or what's to dine it
right there on the island Oh another
dollar what Kenny Rogers do you talking
no no I know the diner you're talking
about the one that there's like that old
school e1 on Highland on the island and
sunset no Highland on Hollywood right by
the wax museum yes well yeah but the
dude I've been to that down else I've
been to that diner we've had lunch there
before I've had lunch there once one
time but I I think it Demelza
it smells but in the middle of that
block Lee was the Kenny Rogers roasters
and I'm gonna go in there before lunch
one day yeah and the people who were in
there the people who were working I
guess one of those things I put the
order in and run away I look behind the
kitchen I'm like I wonder if I get my
money back yes it was too late this
thing was [ __ ] disgusting it was just
disgusting
we had put in order and I guess the guy
had a scab on his face oh no and he was
itching his face and all the sudden I
put my order in and he's bleeding and I
you're bleeding give me it was like huh
like you can't get you can't see that
you're bleeding on your face it's like
okay you're believing can you go clean
yourself up
yeah Kenny Rogers was a [ __ ] be my
god that was disgusting yeah it's tough
to uh being a dad and doing all this and
aspect but right now Mercy's a days
where you can if you dip out for two
weeks she she notices but it doesn't
affect her George is at the age right
now we're at effexor where she's like
like wow why why you have to like she's
really excited that tour got cancelled
believe it or not it affects him because
they act different yeah they told my
wife at school she goes this certain day
she comes in and she's not the same
yeah you know and tell you those that's
cuz he was out of town he's an Walker he
didn't talk to one of the [ __ ] it is so
like I said I had a child when I was 30
and I wasn't this I wasn't dissing thues
like if seem more mature I mean that and
because of that it meant that I was
doing the wrong thing I was doing all
the wrong what was bad so now it's not a
chore to me I know what I have to do
this last week we had her off me and my
wife held it together I would watch her
from 9:00 to 10:30 and then she would
come back from yoga I go to jujitsu and
we come back and we meet eat something
then I do my [ __ ] thing
yeah you know my ages took me out to
dinner tonight and the whole
conversation was about me doing three
weeks a month and that was like guys
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen I love doing my podcast I love
focusing on the podcast I love spending
time my family I loved those weekends
off and I'm 53 when I go out there I
bang it out those shows a path I gotta
take a picture everybody you do two
shows on the Friday and Saturday when I
go back to my room I'm standing there my
feet
knowing into the [ __ ] floor from
energy yeah I'm saw my hips are [ __ ]
so I gotta go back to the room and do
mobility [ __ ] drills and take a
shower at the end of the night go
[ __ ] get up early and catch the first
flight out all that [ __ ] runs on you man
it builds it builds [ __ ] you and those
[ __ ] planes are filled with malaria
and cancer
they got radiation on those [ __ ]
planes you know it's like smoking 22
cigarettes every time you fly really hey
I'll tell you what I started noticing I
was getting bloated in my ankles on
planes that's why you got it you got to
sit there when you sit there you got to
do pump legs because the Chinese
consider the calf to pump up at the
bottom half of your body really yeah
that's why you got to do that you have
to do leg raises like toe raises when
you sitting there on a plane so I'll sit
down every couple of minutes that's why
you get stoned because you'll think
about it
[ __ ] I've never smoked pot on a plane
either pot cookie get on the [ __ ]
plane I gotta try that one with me sit
on you get nice and [ __ ] baked but
you do this with your ankles when you
get on a plane and the Chinese I
mr. acupuncture they consider that the
calf is to pump to the lower body so
your ankles won't get [ __ ] stranger
so I do calf raises yeah right there
right while I'm sitting there right
there I just do this every 22 minutes
and then every 35 minutes I get up and
walk to the [ __ ] bathroom I take my
time even if I don't have to go to the
bathroom I go to the bathroom yeah
because that's why I always sit on one a
1:1 seat whatever that that first house
yeah dang that's my seat
bulkhead for a tile that's I sell that's
the that's my seat that's my seat yeah
I'm a front Frenchman's [ __ ] and I got
direct I'm watching that bathroom the
whole [ __ ] time and I'm watching a
little dirty [ __ ] in there every time
she goes to the back I hit a bit of a
vapor pen and put it right back down and
blow the smoke on the blanket you gotta
work it from all angles Birkin I told
you I just stopped drinking on planes
right yeah because you can calms you
down your anxiety yeah I can't imagine
getting an anxiety attack on a plane
this is my biggest fear in my bag I have
xanax valium snort will you call that
[ __ ] even though I don't use it no more
cocaine no the [ __ ] oh never a spray I
have every anti-anxiety thing I could
have just in case q-tips that marijuana
never does it that was the only time
I've ever flown on edibles was the last
time we went to Austin I'm gonna do it
this time too so I know cuz you do it at
4 a.m. but it's just that was the only
time and I wasn't willing to ID a my
heartbeat just started going and that
you can't I don't like getting up and
moving on planes so like especially as a
bigger dude and I was I was big when I
how much weight have you lost about 90
pounds I like I walk him insanely Thank
You Man
I've ever so good you look fantastic I'm
trying it's uh my diet hasn't been as
good but I've been working at home so
it's I mean you work out a lot
you look good I mean I'm the skinniest
I've been in a long time but I'm still
[ __ ] fat so it's a tough journey
yeah tough journey after a certain age
and you add that to the mix you know you
want to take care of yourself you know
there's not a lot of comedians that are
like 20 years ago
the name comics that you hear weekend
things anymore you know did he ever
crash and then he got [ __ ] up in
Pittsburgh yeah on the second show that
doesn't exist in I know there used to be
all the time all the [ __ ] time
between Mitch Hedberg and popular Aldo
Geraldo and Geraldo and Harford they
were like I was like Oh
draw was just here and they were like
yeah it was bad he took too much xanax
and he had to lay on the floor and did
his set laying on his back on the floor
because the room was spinning I did that
in Bangla really yeah yeah we tell me
that story
you know what the most outstanding thing
from the story is what that a floor and
a clock Saturday night I call slain hams
brother he was a Wigga
hens a rapper at the time this is 2005
the longest joy it was just came up I'm
in Beaumont Texas I told the story on
Marc Maron it was not laughter Marc
Maron podcast in the TV show was not a
lot or not a scripted thing that was a
personal story that I went that guy
picked me up I got in the car and I go
where I was I'm [ __ ] lit I had 30
valiums
30 10 milligram values and three days
drinking jäger meister on ass job next
time you get Joshua ass Josh local Josh
will tell me the story of my Joey Diaz
in Beaumont Texas they know about thirds
I went down there but anyway I went to
buy coke and there were neo-nazis I'm
talking it's behind Beaumont Texas a
neighborhood behind Beaumont Texas so
it's a little bit on the rough end and I
went down and Slade told me his brother
goes listen before we go in there I just
want you to know they ain't friendly
with [ __ ] people of your skin I said
listen you see this is his fallibility
everybody loves for $1 bills I don't
give a [ __ ] who you hating yeah and I
went in there and they talk to me they
even asked my national now that was
Cuban I was drawn out of my [ __ ] mind
I couldn't even talk yeah the volumes
had me going I was [ __ ] like it was
horrible that was the last memory of
that weekend really and then you had to
do a show that night
I did the show Thursday Friday and
Saturday I flew in Thursday and the kid
was supposed to have to blow for me
because I got no blow what can you get
me what can you do when he goes I get
your Valley he told me in a game
whatever the price was so he goes it's
dirty
I go fine just bring me thirty whatever
I don't need I bring back to my friend
in LA and Hollywood the Dave Ramsey I'll
bring him back for him yeah I started
poppin poppin first night like a 1 then
2 then I went to the [ __ ] bar and I
drank a little bit I didn't get coked up
the first night went back to the hotel
got up did some radio you know went back
to the room felt ok oh good yeah popped
another one to sleep at 3 universe feel
good that's the crazy thing about those
slept till about 6:00 got up and was a
little groggy I had some qualifier you
had a couple [ __ ] candle lights you
know I had some [ __ ] pop at those and
went to the show left the show I started
power once I knew the coke was coming I
started pop them up Friday night top and
pop him pop there was a little brown bag
so I wouldn't count I would just pop my
[ __ ] tic tacs Friday now it was gone
I must have gotten to bed at 1 I slept
till 3:30 or next afternoon one of those
things you just wake up your stomach's
empty yeah you [ __ ] up like you need
coffee more coffee a shower another
shower you got a jerk-off you got to go
for a walk take another nap was one of
those days and had two shows and again I
went in the bag and took a handful then
put him in my pocket and the coke came
and then we did the first show and the
first show people was telling me yeah my
says Beaumont Texas this was a great
little comedy room that was owned by two
guys and the one guy robbed the other
one then the guy hit him in the head
with a bamboo thing man that was the end
of that [ __ ] - sure tremendous yes
sir it was first owned by two black
people it was very successful black
copper world kids had a theater in MoMA
and the kid was a bartender and they
quit the business the kid that was the
bartender opened up his own Club he's
funny he's a great kid Slade am so this
Saturday night
club I got the package I'm not hitting
it on stage though so I wouldn't do
coconut stains on before I would do coke
afterward yeah so I do the first show
when I'm [ __ ] happen because that
valuables I took Thursday and those ones
I took Friday that's doing you sis oh oh
they don't go anywhere
Hercule 8:00 and like them up open all
the fat cells holding on to fat cells
every time you get a joint you get even
more fun so it ignites one of those fats
every time you have a cocktail it just
pulls another faster oh c'mon let it out
so if you eat a 10 milligram valium your
fat takes half of it five milligrams get
ruined gets released in your bloodstream
the other five go in your [ __ ] fat
and they just get stored and started
here you are doing gin and tonics you
don't even need Cosby to show up nature
works itself here after 392 readings
annex chicks will tell you they black
out I don't funds a chick leave those
animals and all that [ __ ] they black out
when they [ __ ] drink yeah that should
adds to it so don't think that so here I
am 400 pounds sweating profusely on
stage I'm so hammered the first shot I
laid them that sending shots I'm
drinking 16 shots on stall I'm 400
[ __ ] pounds I already got the
eight-ball it's [ __ ] beige beige
beige this coat was right from the
cartel from the card is beige oh my god
babe
and when it smelled through the paper I
could smell the [ __ ] eat the right
through the paper I was like oh this is
gonna be a good night go back to the
hotel room I'm gonna take a [ __ ] and I
had a plane from Houston like 7:30 in
the morning I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
snort this [ __ ] a ball I got a drink
and all of a sudden I go to the [ __ ]
bathroom I come out of the bathroom and
there's a broad waiting and she's like
she went to a couple had a coat and I
got the coke in my pocket but she's got
some and she like what do you want to do
it you have a car
so we got the woman's bathroom we do a
few bumps in the woman's bathroom she
leaves and next thing you know I [ __ ]
pass out I get up the coke is still
there my money's still that the phone's
ringing I can't [ __ ] even I can't
move yeah but it was horrible I
definitely od'd if it wasn't for my
blood type and my experience I would
have been dead because I remember
getting up my guys like you got to check
out or give me 48 dollars but I just
gave him like a 50 I couldn't even talk
I went back to bed got up at 8:00 puked
went back to bed I finally got a Monday
and call my wife like I finally called
Terry like Monday I'm like Terry and I
gotta believe this I'm [ __ ] up yeah
and I stayed in that hotel room till
Tuesday and I had my friend come and get
me and take me to this [ __ ] thing so
what happened the flight who knows I
didn't come to till Thursday I didn't
really start talking like I had one
minute it was Saturday and the next
minute it was [ __ ] Thursday good God
like that's how [ __ ] deep I was into
drugs day but I was [ __ ] sick till
Thursday you know what it took me is
teeth nervously please put all that for
that that was it was those bars those an
bars those an Baz knows a [ __ ] bat
child then we had a friend addicted to
those and they wouldn't even take him in
rehab why cuz you got it I guess you got
a like benzos are the hardest to detox
off of they're real dangerous I I used
to take a ton of benzos what a benzos
that's the classification for Xanax and
Valium is a benzo dieting or whatever
and so mother really dangerous to come
off of because you can I guess you have
a stroke if you're overdose saying your
body's dependent on them it's really
hard but uh I had a buddy they wouldn't
even take him into rehab they would like
they denied him rehab they like tell him
to get off benzos first yeah I was I was
what is that you're burning I'm trying
to burn this off so they stick it into
the pipe it doesn't stick and attract
all the other [ __ ] I see it goes nice
and easy like the night wind but yeah if
you want you blondie you wanna bong are
you gonna sit there like jolly little
Mort don't [ __ ] bother us this is the
pure cush room from bugs and roses that
plays over a mint or we do not go into
the other spot him I got a perennial but
I gotta mix it up I've been gone
apprentice for the last year that's all
the same growers so you get used to
their whole mix after a while you know
so let me try something else
Josh wolf goes to bud and Rose this let
me go up there and see what it's about
very nice people very nice people very
knowledgeable either very they explain
everything
in fact they explain too much like they
tell you too much they don't want to
know this much just give me this [ __ ]
they kill Lucifer and I'll be on my way
they want to talk to you about histories
and what the cannabis carpet you know
yeah but they're very nice [ __ ]
people
they're very nice being with a girl with
knowledge until fried water some sonic
boom some pure cush and I said that's a
teeth I got was [ __ ] really good now
do you notice the difference between
sativas and indicas yes you do there's a
difference I could smell the difference
really smelling this a team and the
indica and I could also when I get high
like I could I liked sativas that get me
[ __ ] stoned
yeah I don't want to smoke us at Eve of
that dick to me and then everybody else
is like did you feel the body and I
listen I don't want to Bonnie out kick
myself in the stomach you don't say and
release [ __ ] my adrenals yeah what's
going on over there ding no but it but I
had actually a question for you
you seem like a very extroverted person
yeah but I listen to your podcast and
you always talk you talk a lot about
like feeling nervous or anxious or like
worrying about what people think
yeah and that's my world like that's
like I was thinking about it if we went
to high school together I would have
hated you but wanted to be you know you
like me and you would have gotten along
really well
you think so like in my head you seem
like a partier like a cool guy and I
just wasn't so but so it
surprise it always surprises me or eise
to surprise me a lot when people who
seem to be extroverted in love being the
life of the party
are going through some of the same
issues yeah yeah you know it's so funny
I don't I I've really been regretting it
my honesty because I've shared way too
much on my podcast people know
everything about me and I started going
like I should have played this cool like
like you know like and just told
everyone I was cool and I was a badass
and I don't [ __ ] have anxiety attacks
on planes and I don't drink boxes of
wine and whatever the [ __ ] secrets I
should have kept but yeah man I I have I
got diagnosed with with social anxiety
disorder when I first moved to LA some
doctor told me I had it and I was like
you ready [ __ ] mind I'm a comedian and
he goes okay and I just left and then I
realized oh yeah I don't like one of the
things that drives me nuts is like going
to like The Improv and and I don't know
people's names and just I get like
embarrass I don't know their names and
they know me and then go on like hey
like it and like and like I don't like
answer on my phone I don't like checking
my messages like I just it's like I rely
I'm kind of a neurotic regularly like
Joey knows like the half there times I
do spots Joey knows this for a fact is
because Joey calls me and goes you're
coming with me let's go and he just
picks me up and we go to a spot like I
have a hard time calling in for avails
like just that phone call gives me
anxiety
oh yeah I can imagine I used to love not
like a lot of times you'll hear people
be like I love when people cancelled
plans I used to love when people
wouldn't answer the phone like if I
would call them to like oh maybe we
should do something if I call them and
they don't enter the phone oh great I
like I used to get it but it's weird
because I would get bummed about in high
school I got be bummed like oh everyone
else is out but I would never get call
someone and talk to him talk to them
know know if I wasn't at the movies or
or at my best friend's house like the
one friend I had there's no chance of me
going I flew into South Africa one night
and I had to meet up with my whole crew
and their flights got did postponed so
they weren't coming in until like 24
hours later and I just
I literally was like oh I'm locking down
in this hotel room hard [ __ ] core ila
and I loved it I like I like I remember
I woke up I had nothing to do all day
and I like we had a little pools out by
our our we had little Suites that had
pools that overlook the ocean and I like
got out my pool and they came back and
took watched a movie and [ __ ] had a
glass of wine it was almost the [ __ ]
best I love it
my wife calls a cave time she's like
every man needs cave time we're like you
go in and you don't [ __ ] talk to
anybody and you just disappear inside
you and you get small I love that
feeling I feel that becoming a comedian
gave me social anxiety the last 12 years
so that's crazy because I really believe
little social anxiety forever
I don't I can't I can't believe that
even when I was creeping and I was a
creepy dude and robbing people and I'd
have to walk into that bar right and
three people would say that [ __ ]
robbed that drug dealer I wouldn't get
anxiety I would look at them like who
gives a [ __ ] obviously you're not doing
nothing like in my mind I would give him
that type of look I didn't get social
anxiety like I get now I think the
calmly over the years gave it to me they
flipped the switch too much it was too
much somewhere you get overstimulated
one night you just don't come back i I
one of the roughest things for me is for
me to go on the road and my behavior on
the road now it's what is sort of very
Jack Nicholson in [ __ ] that movie
well he's just a [ __ ] nut one fluid
level no the other one when he's a nut
what is it no when he when he's a
[ __ ] writer and he's with Helen Hunt
and he washes his hands and he doesn't
have friends
yeah yeah it's racist and he's [ __ ]
whatever well nothing I'm racist I'm
just saying that when I travel now
because of my situation okay if I was
single when I travel now I would
a completely different person yeah in a
couple of extremes I wouldn't mean that
I'm still drinking do blow I'm just
saying that I would now because the
situation we're in when we are alone I
missed that those two girls I missed my
wife and daughter but when we call and
they're at that thing and they're
playing in the house and you're in the
hotel room and you just relaxing and the
only thing you have on your mind whether
it's to get the steak or the chicken
Florentine from room service because
you're not even leaving the [ __ ] room
oh yeah you've already known like I'm
not leaving this [ __ ] room I will not
leave that room so the next more I will
not leave that room at all okay I will
not leave that room at all and people
really don't understand that since we
have so much activity when we go on the
road now it's a [ __ ] it's my piece
yeah I don't want to go to dinner I
don't want to go to the movies mm-hmm I
don't want to meet you know where I
don't want to go to I'm not you're not
gonna see me in a [ __ ] bar kill me
place you're gonna see me at the hotel
gym yeah and at the [ __ ] hotel
whatever is downstairs or whatever is
down the block I love these people call
me though there's a fantastic Cuban
restaurant how close is it to the hotel
28 malls it's not happening dude people
tell me people tell me that happen if
people tell me yeah we get down the show
and they're like Bert come out with us I
go where you unless it's the bar a
crucial word of the hotel or next door
to the club I'm at I'm not getting in a
car driving to downtown yeah man I got
stuck in Omaha no I get stuck in Des
Moines for like two days because of
weather and a man it was beautiful the
girls weren't home they were on the road
so I was just flying they were like in
Tampa or something and I got up and they
called me and I said your flights been
postponed we were trying to get you on a
flight tomorrow but all flights today
have been canceled and we're having a
hard time we may not be able to get you
out until Wednesday and this is [ __ ]
Monday morning and I go you know what
don't worry about it and I sat in a
hotel Monday and Tuesday and I like
planned out my day I was like I'm going
to the
movies I'm gonna go to Buffalo Wild
Wings I'm gonna go look at shoes over
the Nike outlet I'm gonna go back into
my room I'm gonna take an ambien at at
at at [ __ ] 6:00 and go to sleep wake
up at 2:00 in the morning go see if I
have a glass of wine and watch it like I
just love that [ __ ]
disappearing man I know I have some type
of socially but I'm not gonna go get a
pill for it yeah oh no need yeah I just
deal with whatever if my body says I'm
not the [ __ ] mood you're in no danger
oh I guess what I'm not yeah ever ever
ever
yeah I cannot go to see a movie in the
premiere those all those social type
events don't eyes dude I look at on long
gone I wish I had you know who does
who's really good at it is Brandi Shaw
he goes to like movie premieres all the
time and loves that and I just look at
it and I go I wish I loved it I would be
sitting I guess if you're like if I
guess if I had to go to a premiere and
being in the movie and sitting there as
two different parking situations yeah
two different [ __ ] situation what do
you mean
being in the movie yeah and now you
gotta sit there with 200 [ __ ] people
who are sitting looking at you every
time the movie comes on I was on a
[ __ ] plane one time and by the grace
of God grudge match was a grudge match
is on it's in the [ __ ] plane and I'm
sitting there next to Rogen and Rogen is
like this is this a movie and I'm like
that mm-hmm he goes back to bed I'm
sitting there and I could see the chicks
next to me like looking and also at one
point they go and I'm like like I didn't
even know what the [ __ ] to do when you
go to a permian you have to sit there oh
and look at your shitty [ __ ] movie
and make believe it's funny and the
people behind you or laughing at your
jokes because they know you're sitting
there kind of [ __ ] disgusting hey I
pee what but the best was DeNiro a
grudge match premiere out called slept
how cold are you serious movie started
his head tipped back and next thing I
saw his mouth open up like the flat dude
and in
in seven men when they found the fat his
mouth opened up it was like that and he
[ __ ] slept throughout the whole movie
when the movie got up he was tip-top
Magoo he was shaking hands and taking
pictures like he enjoyed the [ __ ]
movie
shut up you said who wants to sit and
watch that's the whole thing
I don't go no permeate listen if Bert
Kreischer says to me I'm gonna [ __ ]
De Niro movie I'm gonna still on movie
I'm gonna Jason's dream movie my wife
can't go will you go with me I would go
with you because I know what you're
gonna go through yeah and I could calm
you down while you're there a little bit
I know exactly what to do I get up I get
up yeah I act likely acting at that
[ __ ] gas station you said you acted
weird with Paula like Here I am sitting
at the premiere along this yard and next
to me is Cameron Crowe the guy from yeah
yeah yeah either no yeah that's Russell
Russell Crowe's with Damon is okay and
I'm sitting behind the producers of The
Longest Yard this is how [ __ ] I
lifted my left it's Russell Crowe and I
go holy [ __ ] but the best thing he had
just shots in their own bed oh yeah oh
man there's about a movie about a guy in
my neighborhood yeah as we were all grew
up we we used to shovel his [ __ ]
drive when he give us dollars in the
winter yeah well over that guy's name
was and he had the jacket on that said
Cinderella man North Bergen New Jersey
and something else and then look over
hey man that movie you did about
whatever the [ __ ] guy's the Iceman no
no what about the [ __ ] boxer yeah the
one about the boxer of a candy Roy or
Hudson Henry Hudson Park no what the
[ __ ] is it what was it Lee Church wasn't
relevant I've been sinner oh yeah type
in the name a Hudson Hudson Jesus Christ
I'm getting old
not cinderelly
yeah Cinderella Man what's cool what's
the name of the [ __ ] star of the
movie what's the crime James Pratt J
Braddock Braddock Braddock Park is a
park in my hometown in North Bergen
because he lived by that yeah so when I
saw the jacket I go hey man that [ __ ]
movie dude that's gonna be the movie of
the year and the producers of my movie
is sitting in front of me and they all
turn around like what the [ __ ] did you
just say yeah I was like dog dog it's
about a guy from where I grew up the
[ __ ] I scrubbed all his grandkids
that I'm not kidding you there were no
more cops they all lived afterwards who
gives a [ __ ] that's what they okay
that's the difference between you I
don't know if you have social anxiety as
much as you don't [ __ ] around with
idiots well no that's how you feel
that's how I take care of my anxiety
yeah by acting completely out of a box
everybody knows I would never say two
words that [ __ ] Russell Crowe anybody
else's magic yeah I would sit there
watch the movie if he said something to
me then I'd say something to him yeah I
would never tap him on the shoulder go
I love gladiator can I take a picture I
wouldn't do that to the poor guy that
guy's trying to sit down enjoy [ __ ]
movie yeah but that's what I said to him
what I remember I did that so I wouldn't
get that anxiety but the thing that
broke me out of that was one night I
just happened to turn Letterman on and
[ __ ] was on there who the guy would
think she's 20 but he's really 90 Doug
Stanhope hangs out with Johnny Depp
Johnny Depp is on and he's talking about
that leather it's like so this movie
you've just did it how does it look yeah
nothing bracelets and I make up your
[ __ ] 55 did nobody [ __ ] oh and we
tried to guess it yeah he shows up he
shows up rebound advances bands with
bracelets on and t-shirt but you know
what he's not a baguette artist I gotta
give you that much Johnny that Johnny
Depp is across the board a [ __ ] great
actor
oh no he's tremendous he's an amazing
actor but I [ __ ] say it was a bad act
the way no no no no no no [ __ ] oh you
can start of gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] oh I don't
know him the guy believed the nice guy
you know [ __ ] oh he'd understand the
game Joey has just figuring out what
should be a game show Joey describes
celebrities and you go [ __ ] oh he's 20
but he's really 50 so what we turn it
down you don't know oh you saw him on
Letterman I saw him on let him he was
talking about let me set them when you
shoot your [ __ ] movies do you watch
them he goes I don't watch dick and
Levin goes we would have said what are
you talking about you don't want dailies
you just listen
I don't watch dick I let him in those
beat your what's his name Johnny -
Johnny Depp and he goes listen I don't
want to see me and I don't want to hear
my [ __ ] boy she didn't say [ __ ]
but he meant to like I'm right there I
gained confidence cuz that's what I have
yeah so does I hear my voice I gotta go
I'll do a minute a minute and a half not
even not even one minute is only there
was hear your voice especially when
somebody else is in a robe that's even
more embarrassing when somebody else is
in the [ __ ] room Wow
so he said he goes I don't watch nothing
because it tears me apart because I
shoot it and I go yeah so I knew there
wasn't something wrong with me I knew
that somebody else suffered from this
[ __ ] I just don't like it I went to
premieres and they were fun but they
were for [ __ ] I shot which really puts a
little [ __ ] pressure on you you don't
say that and then like for spider-man to
they were asking me to do other like
things I said no I couldn't I couldn't
handle that one [ __ ] machine the
movie well I'm gonna go make believe
like I'm the star the [ __ ] movie for
ya so I went to the cast and crew and
then I went to the regular premiere but
they won't do you want to go to New York
premiere whatever because Oprah liked
that scene yeah I was like [ __ ] I'm too
embarrassed to [ __ ] do that [ __ ] so I
didn't go to that one I went to grudge
match because it was DeNiro
I had to go out of respect for him yeah
[ __ ] Stallone [ __ ] everybody else I had
to go for him and I went to the longest
shot and that was just embarrassing why
cuz I was 400 pounds
I couldn't fit in a tuxedo so I had a
wear warm-up suit given to me my Big
Daddy
you know the whole line I was there I
wanted to snort but I couldn't and
everything was there like everything was
there yeah free booze champagne pills
narcotics steroids I couldn't know
whatever I wanted said like so why
didn't you because I didn't want to show
Adam that he put me in this [ __ ]
movie
you know I didn't want him to even see a
dab of me under the [ __ ] influence
and there'll be other people there and
they will wait for me to do that dude
I'm saying yeah they knew they were
suspect that I was a junkie but they had
never seen it with their own eyes
this is what they're expecting this is
your channel everybody's going they're
going I wonder what the [ __ ] he's
gonna be doing below tonight so I can't
do blow I would always keep him tricked
and then they would somebody would say
so he's a junkie well he was at the
premiere he wasn't even drinking and he
seemed okay to me
you know saying so it's when they expect
you and you don't get [ __ ] high that
that's the whole trick of it so I
wouldn't get high you don't want them to
have the ammunition to say yes should
have seen him on the biggest night of
his life he was [ __ ] him [ __ ]
habit but just not handle with your jaw
going from side to side you're 400
pounds you're sweating profusely people
know people [ __ ] don't know I mean
yeah I didn't if you would have told me
this ten years ago I would have said no
many [ __ ] knows I get away with it
know everybody knows everybody knows you
your skin color changes I see people now
and I know it's doable
really oh yeah I've got shows now now I
see them and I know they're doing blow
by two ways two actions and the color of
their skin because I recognized it from
the color of my [ __ ] skin was Tony
Bennett [ __ ] Thomason
it's late it's late but early do you put
this in the eye like this it's clogged
up I gotta [ __ ] take it home and boil
it [ __ ] catch blood or some [ __ ]
hey Tom Bert doing good
how are you feeling I'm pretty good it's
not I'm not I'm not gonna going crazy
which I thought I'd be going [ __ ]
we're making a couple [ __ ] noises
again I heard them I didn't know what
was going on I saw you the very
beginning of this and you when Joey said
something you closed your eyes and
you're I was watching you try to ride
the inside of your eyelids oh yeah oh
yeah no there's there's been a couple
moments where I've been a little out of
it now when do you shoot you special I
shot it when I already stopped when like
uh two months ago okay that's who you
was Santa you and you started with a
really new material for the new hour but
I'm gonna be on set it's going slow
oh it you always does if you only want
one than a week yeah if you go out six
nights a week you'll get ten minutes a
[ __ ] week that's what I always
figured out myself really I want to go
to the comic store two nights a week oh
when you walk in the final Dave
Chappelle Road yeah we're gonna try you
a story about Iowa at 11 o'clock at
night you have you don't have the heart
to know so you catch yourself doing the
same [ __ ] material to baby you don't
wanna look like an [ __ ] so what I did
was cut out the store wouldn't matter -
and now I go to different haunts like we
go to Tuesday nights to the Black Horse
or whatever the [ __ ] you call and you do
30 minutes 20 minutes it's something
different I don't have to feel like
[ __ ] down you told CAA is in the
[ __ ] room or whatever I don't need
that aggravation you told us joke the
other night I don't even know if it was
you've meant to tell it but I had
written a joke similar to it on Saturday
but my joke was so much weaker than your
choke and as soon as I heard a
commanding mouth I was like [ __ ] I was
like son of a [ __ ] man I need to get on
stage more because you just ripped it I
don't even know if you would even
remember it but as soon as I heard it I
went [ __ ] I got a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] hustle I want to start doing the
haha more again - if I tase them yeah
the house where I got the best pet yeah
you tell him how you want to close the
shows in the week yeah tell out close
both [ __ ] shows basically but more
importantly up close delayed show
yeah let me do two spot somewhere else I
like the islands ahaha energy yeah if
you go and I like to haha on Wednesday
nights it's a great place it's a great
place but juniors night let's shout you
right now I'm about listen I'm to the
point in my life that I can't do
something for six weeks like right now
if somebody came to me as a Joey we have
a sitcom it's gonna be 11 weeks okay 11
episodes how many episodes am i doing
eight can I do five like you follow me
up to that point cuz I know you get to
an age and you know yeah they come to
you with all this [ __ ] and money you
know you know let me tell you something
listen I appreciate this and I
appreciate that I appreciate this but I
can't cover that spread yeah if I had to
do the whole eyeball tour that's tough
yeah that's tough waking up and [ __ ]
west bomb and I gotta take a plane to
Tampa then waking up again and taking an
8 hour car ride that that's tough for 3
or 4 weeks in a row
we earned your [ __ ] Jesus I was
dreading that [ __ ] you know why cause I
can't do that though I can't do that I
can basically go into a comedy club
Thursday through Sunday morning you got
five good shows up yeah if I go on the
road for three weeks on the road I feel
bad those third week does it become a
robot I really don't want to do it yeah
I really don't want to do what I do
because they tricked me they switched
the week they they'll give me an extra
500 a holiday you know and you're like
against yourself and when you're there
you're burnt out yeah I could do two on
two off all day long I can do well I can
do three I can do three in a row I get a
three in a row two on one offs great two
on one off yeah [ __ ] I'm doing three and
uh it's like right right when what was
it a September but are we in August
September October and October I start
back up again like I'm I'm off I do one
date I think in set very beginning of
September September 9th 10th 11th I'm in
Toledo and then I'm off until and then I
go on cow heads cruise for a
and I start up hard in October I do
three on one off I can't believe you
already have New Year's yeah Jesus
you're a bad [ __ ]
no no you know what it is I don't know
I'll tell you all fair it's not I'll
tell you off so you do have New Year's
yeah okay yeah but I don't have it three
years nobody's even offered me a [ __ ]
New Year's really but you know what man
if you come to me with New Year's I tell
you again I think I'll turn it down
anyway and I think my age and I really
put that buzz I told him the truth I
want the ice house yeah the backroom one
eight o'clock hey I got offered New
Year's originally what real early but it
was just a conversation with you know
with Grossman and he's just talking
about it he's like hey you learned in
New Year's we're in the same room
together and I was like yeah and the
only reason it took off said he offered
me I thought pretty solid money but
someone said they'd get me more money
and they were like let's see if we can
get you more money
I told Grossman I said I'm gonna see if
I can get more money and he was like
that's fine and I got more money but it
was like it was a lotta moves that like
I wanna say it was like two months ago
that I got new years but it was all
based on Grossman Marc Grossman just
saying hey do you want to do New Year's
in like he's I think it's a in Pitt and
Philly so but you know I'm a good New
Year's AK side drink so I think some
clubs were like let's grab him for New
Year's now real early at a low price
before he's got a New Year's booked so
it's really crazy how when you drink on
stage or beer sales or alcohol sales
like 50% more through the fall and it
kills me that I'll do a shot at two from
time to time but I can't put him down
like you know what I put him down you go
to Texas and you start toasting them
don't do one for I'm doing dude I just
got I just started working in Texas
again I'll do it next year
San Antonio I've never done it before
year there's no San Antonio seventeen
years ago
lol now look this was a different one
this was a rim the center of the mall
yeah I'm doing San Antonio for the first
time I'm excited to you know
our podcast numbers are big in Texas
like why Majan we probably the same
podcast demographics like Ohio don't go
to Houston or Dallas
never I used to go to Dallas a bunch
and I got one complaint and they stopped
bringing me in no it does not take that
back that's that's inaccurate I did get
a poke a complaint and I don't think I
did it the next year but they've given
me offers and I've canceled on them so
no and my guy at Texas was Trey but then
he I think he got fired for got fired
but I that was the guy I love try I
thought he was great and then it in
Houston I used to do laughs stop for
Pete Pete Pirelli you remember him yeah
he just texted me the other day he's got
a new wife Pete was one of the best
comedy club owners I have a work for
dude towards the end of my cocaine reign
he was he had the best club in the world
and Pete and the guy who had it before
him it was also a big drug that alcohol
Club when you went to Houston for five
days oh my god yeah you were gonna come
back [ __ ] see if you could see Joey
Diaz cold case from 2000 and if it
somebody put it up online I want to show
you what I'd look like really have to be
in Houston for two weeks
did pH mean the sugar in the
Jagermeister the [ __ ] two eggs with
french fries and toast at the Greek
place yeah and the [ __ ] uh the
kawatche cheese and the [ __ ] this and
that and this and that
listen it's it's a goddamn shame
it's a [ __ ] shame that club that was
probably I didn't want drugs at that
[ __ ] club than a club and then people
rally took it over and I Pete used to
let me stay on his partner's house they
said you could stay at the hotel they
gotta come get you or who you're saying
that in a in the in the condos where he
lived with his wife and his parent
across I see yeah cross the whole way he
was a big video gamer oh my god and
they'd skate they'd [ __ ] see me the
next thing go did you did you call a
pizza last night in the middle of night
and I go no why they go all we heard
cause that's my drug dealer
I wouldn't never tell them you know they
had run it watch how big I was looking
two weeks
one straight that'll Isis two weeks
after [ __ ] being in Houston this is
what that would look like swallows in
the soil this 2000 2002 2003 maybe about
that search warrant for mr. wheelies
backside I'll never forget that morning
and my girl that the time picking me up
going Joey you gave my twenty pounds do
this favor
step on out of there I was like Raffi
Oh remember bending the nose candles Oh
Joey the Bell
yeah oh yeah yeah turns out he was
murdered before the fire broke out look
at the size of that stomach ain't it
look at my neck told me weird you didn't
like got a crime he was up early cause
he was a Jew
Joey cuz he was a drag long [ __ ] time
ago and you're kind of a Cheney right
relax the drug bust
Wow yeah look at the size of my stomach
I had no chest
room like the cash selling merchandise
mr. champ
except you used more than you sold ended
up on Cheney a lot of money heard you
had a real damn Joey you don't even look
you know I'm Sonali enough we [ __ ]
watch that some embarrassed enough
that's me after two weeks in Houston
Texas
wow what does it make you feel like when
you see that I hate looking at pictures
of myself a little that was a complete
different person man I was running with
[ __ ] diva when I shot this she had
date mr. 2003 yeah yeah
how [ __ ] scary that's right he used
to work that it I used to love that club
that was the first place that headlined
me me too
maybe but I got it Lee uh
I want to say I want to say I I mean he
I brought came in
Dane Cook was supposed to do a date and
he backed out for the last minute and
they plugged me in and with and and I
went in and I did I had a good time but
I drank a lot and I'm burp eats and your
numbers won't go but my bar sales were
the same as like so he's like I'll have
you back and then he said you just had a
baby I'll break this is 2004 he's like
I'll bring you in I'll bring you in for
Thanksgiving I'll pay you three grand
which by the way for people not knowing
anything about comedy if you for your
second time had Lundy I make 3 grand is
ridicu ridiculous anything you said I'll
put you up you can bring
the baby down it was Thanksgiving
George's first Thanksgiving we stayed in
a hotel room and we got Thanksgiving
delivered to our room for free was part
of the package and dude we ate three
Thanksgiving meals that day it was one
of my favorite weekend's on the road
ever I walked with a three grand and I
was like we're [ __ ] rich
but yeah Pete was good to me he was
really good really good ten and willing
it was drank hard I still talk to Pete I
texted him I don't pee once a month
out of respect Pete his wife used to
work for Pepsi so she got a tortoise
they got divorced they got divorced this
is how close I was with Pete his ex-wife
they got divorced and she called me the
one time 3p popped me in and picked me
up with her friend and took me to dinner
to buy themselves to tell me that they
were getting divorced
and I was like oh [ __ ] she was like
listen I still want to be friends with
you I bought Georgia some presents and I
and I gave me presents for Georgia and I
went Pete was like it's all cool I heard
you guys went to dinner like you know
just you know man that was that was
really fun and I was just I'm working
with Bob Breuder staff Jerry Rocha first
time I work with Jerry Rocha was at one
of those I talked his wife the first
time they'd taken with a picture of her
ass with a thong on Oh at the Houston
laughs stop i tormented Pete's wife so
much I kept saying listen I gotta take a
picture your ass and finally she turned
around and started taking him off my
face got pale because now Pete would
know yeah and Pete nobody say nothing he
just giggled about it cause she's got a
great ass I remember I work with cat
Kathy Griffin one time there it's so
like I was headlining she must have come
in on a Wednesday piece I'd come in
Wednesday feature for Kathy and then you
do Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday I was
like okay so come on Kathy is sold out
sold out and it's it's all gay boots
it's not a woman in the room it's all
gay dudes when I was very young and
comedy and I just I don't know you get
like you're like I'll go up I'll do like
a gay joke girl like I'm a mate I'll
break the ice I just walked up on stage
and I was like what's up [ __ ] and it
went and Kathy like pulled me aside like
why would you
say that and I was like I don't know I
was trying to say something cooler like
I was trying to let them know that I was
cool but I wasn't gonna take [ __ ] and
she's and she was like listen next jokes
we did two shows on Wednesday she was
like next show
just come up be nice to them I worked
with Kevin Setia was her future act and
I went up and I was like that's cause
the gay people from that neighborhood
from Montrose yeah and they were very I
used to go to all the restaurants at
Montrose best food and [ __ ] know they
have a restaurant called Maxwell's
Maxwell's something like that and they
had the best [ __ ] Mountain meatloaf
and while I was eating I'm like these
gay guys are coming into the meatloaf
but I don't go [ __ ] it's that good this
is HIV meatloaf is banging but I don't
give a [ __ ] jack so I I I would do well
in front of Montrose crowd in front of
the gay audience and uh you know I would
just talk dirty and [ __ ] be crazy and
talking about coke and he's next to
saying it they took the ride but that
neighbor there's a strong gain Abel a
really strong yeah really [ __ ] strong
they come out they smoke dope and they
[ __ ] do everything so yeah Danny you
know what I remember one time I didn't
get into somebody you don't like when
you get with a heckle yeah I called when
I called him back and I said what did
you drive here and he goes in a
Volkswagen you were for the [ __ ] and the
book science together somebody's son
somebody's [ __ ] and I had them and I
ran with it but they are already yeah
like me you know saying I used to make
man I did my first album which is
horrible who you listen to it it's
called Bert Bert Bert get download it is
horrible it's not bad but you can hear
how you tape in Houston and Houston yeah
that was that was the home for CDs back
then they give you they give you they
record all your show you show and it was
really good recording because I think
Babbitt sucked stuck it up set it up for
Hedberg and so hep all had bergs albums
were recorded there and so I did my
album out of there I added it it myself
I think I master it for me but yeah I've
got that [ __ ] it's crazy you know
it's crazy to think we're like that was
back we're like someone was like you
have a CD and that you would go like how
could I have a CD like well I don't have
no one signed me to a deal to have a CD
now you look at you like I'll just
record my shows and release it as a CD
like now it's so simple like I we did
that uh I cannot I I mean not to get too
meta fit but like this whole thing
you're talking about like Johnny Depp
not watching him I shot something the
other night just a [ __ ] gag I thought
it would be funny I posted it and it got
like [ __ ] six hundred thousand
downloads on Facebook that's it and like
and then [ __ ] six hundred retweets on
or foreign retweets or 600 tweets on
Twitter and ever and now my aunt my
agents email me and they're like do more
of this [ __ ] you're like I was just
[ __ ] around technology's changed so
much
do you have a [ __ ] idea shoot it as
a joke put it up I don't care if it gets
three thousand views that just means no
one saw it so I'm not embarrassed I put
it up and then all the sudden because I
mean not viral but like viral for me and
then all the sudden it's all over the
map and then your agents would like do
more of it do more of that [ __ ] that's I
just think this business has changed so
[ __ ] much now then you overthink it
then that thing goes big and you over
you that you go I gotta shoot another
one and you overthinking you're like
[ __ ] then you're in your head you're
like I don't know how to do it but those
videos that they're great to shoot Damon
and I shot 200 of them it's just that uh
you need if you're gonna put them out
they need to be heat you know they need
to be heat and some people do well with
them and then they start releasing them
too much - what - yeah and then it dies
it needs to be that's the hard part like
I don't know what to do like what
happened was there was a speedo the Ryan
Lochte thing went down and my buddy Josh
temple is on HDTV and DIY he knows I
[ __ ] around this P I wear speedos all
the time and he goes hey Burt I don't
know if you've heard but there's a hole
in their roster I have these like two
videos that are really funny with drone
shots that I just shot [ __ ] around
for triplet
and so I I post it below the videos and
it gets like good if you like maybe like
400 retweets I was like that's a lot for
me that's a lot and then I know I have
another one so I post another one and
then I was like I'll shoot this this
[ __ ] offer to speed oh I just shot it
like did four takes I used one of the
takes beginning dan post it and then
mass when it blew up and then you start
overthinking it once you overthink it
you're [ __ ] you just like you're like
yeah [ __ ] it I guess I'm done with this
project like why why [ __ ] why
overthink it make it bad let's end on a
high note you know and then my wife's
like like she's like get Joey the whole
premise is on pitch in speedo to be
their new spokesperson because they lost
Ryan Lochte and I was like I'll fill
that hole and I was like oh I can't swim
I'm not that good-looking the speedo but
I'll wear speedos 24 hours a day as long
as I'm under contract and I was like my
agents Mac Stubblefield call me UTA and
then LeAnn goes what you got to do is
you got to do one where Joey is your
agent Mac Stubblefield he just does and
it [ __ ] blows I was like listen
[ __ ] you sign this [ __ ]
like does a Joey rant and you just stand
there in a speedo and you're hero pose
and Joey's just the Puff Daddy like this
[ __ ] look at him look at his
mother look at this topic like just a
rant and I was like yeah but then you
start going like yeah but then I don't
know what have we think yeah right you
look like two [ __ ] idiots we might as
well get a [ __ ] jersey and go to a
game right if the team loses we go to
the Train drive home on the train with
that loser shirt all of these ship Y my
favorite yeah why don't just do a
podcast what we like doing yeah do that
it's it's bleep pull up what can you
pull up my speedo offered oh yeah I saw
it I saw it the other day yeah I didn't
think you were tied iddyn no what the
[ __ ] you were talking about first thing
you said that I thought you had shots on
with the girls okay let me give some
[ __ ] shoutouts here are we wrapping
this up couple minutes couple you can
drink another one open them mother
[ __ ] up please ready to drink Lee
how's those chocolate mushroom treating
it what do you think dog talk to me
they're pretty good I mean you although
bite
absolutely let's do it let's go see the
devil
why not yours Todd let's finish this
[ __ ]
once and for [ __ ] money it's Sunday
night that's the only way it's good for
me
that's how I ate it that day tastes like
[ __ ] the Marshall chocolate tastes a
little funky
I just water water it tasted like didn't
taste good huh it didn't taste good I
just swallowed water woof yes but it's
got some kick to it
it's got some [ __ ] kicked I don't
know what the [ __ ] Bert's talking about
but he's got some kick to it before I
was looking at you Bert and he was gonna
look like your father I'm like always
[ __ ]
but I see you over there making funny
noises sweating and this one I'm
sweating I summon sweating a lot living
I just started drinking again how long
were you sober for well not long like
three weeks you buddy buddy gonna shot
yeah yeah kinda my body was like it was
like I think it just was like here we
gonna party man like we don't we have
nothing to look forward to let's [ __ ]
get down so did you get like that cuz I
always I survived to get a good one like
fast food I'm sweating up your wallet
touch it do not really you eating that
whole thing yeah I made the whole thing
but so like it always used to surprise
me when people would be like oh I went
to McDonald's I feel like [ __ ] I would
go there once a day oh no I mean
opposite so no but one was up so oh so
alcohol does make you feel like [ __ ] no
not at all like that when I when I then
I was I thought I did a pocket podcast
with Christina Pierzynski and I talked
about it so it's not like I'm telling a
secret but I don't want to tell it more
than I have to but like what happened is
that khana quit drinking in that fact
felt so I felt healthy but just wasn't
like cheery
I didn't like I was just like I don't
know I got home and I was like time to
go to bed everybody and then we go to
bed at 8:00 and I wake up at 6:00 I'd be
like okay I'm up coffee and like it just
didn't turn a corner are you back for
that
he goes why do we struggle
I'm Tanya Lee either with this mid Trump
it goes down a lot easy I do it one shot
you go do you do everything in one shot
though because there's less painful you
put you put too much pain you get off
psycho firatli go Lee Lee Lee I'm
telling you you know what a piece of
[ __ ] see it tastes like you're eating
it like a pterodactyl yep it doesn't
taste good just let it melt in your
mouth all over your tongue I have some
of that chocolate with every time you
leave is the way they do it that's
pretty oh that is a picture of why kids
shouldn't do drugs
a few a team get off for YouTube right
now I still gotta go to the comedy store
I think I feel what are you doing is it
stuck on your tooth yeah I don't want
and it has a mushrooms that [ __ ] like
garbage anyway so I don't want to close
my mouth and get mushrooms I'm telling
you get that out of my teeth oh yeah
leave while the funniest man I know
truly they have to give you your old
show on [ __ ] seriously Ethan Buzzard
Matthew Olivares John Cutler my main man
Lorinda Lily Robert Sasso crystal Jordan
crystal Oakes you sexy savage and oaky
spooky Donna and Austin were like
[ __ ] 18 days away from Austin and
we're like 24 days away from New York
City but I'll see you [ __ ]
Wednesday night at the ice house be
there or be square
8:30 what else is going on with you
sorry about that I got a little
emotional that mushroom made me take off
therefore I love this [ __ ] that was
great
what that's a little piece of mushroom I
got nice and giggly before my sons are
Whateley honestly if you are a person
who doesn't like edibles mushrooms
obviously I haven't taken like a huge
dose so no money I don't I can't speak
from that but if you're gonna take a
little mushroom or a little edible take
mushrooms it's lighter like it is
lighter
I do edibles I think are more like I
feel them on my tits and [ __ ] like
mushrooms or more like hey shadow people
yeah you know look I never thought I
always enjoyed I don't like mushrooms at
night I'd rather mushrooms during the
day but yes no if you and I can't do
mushrooms at night because we got the
kids walking I can do it I can't do much
I can't do that [ __ ] at all with mercy
around I can catch the tail end of a pot
cookie and Mercy's going to bed or
something like that I get anxiety when
she jumps on me or something but besides
that I could never do anything like that
around I would have a heart oh I can't
do I live heart attack she's I'm gonna
have to stop smoking soon I'll figure
something different huh really glad I
have the back room I could stash him
they're gonna get in the safe so she
can't get the gummies she can't get
nothing to stash it but I'm trying to
figure out she knows I'm going outside
to smoke she knows she looks at me she
doesn't know what it is no but she looks
at my hand when I walk back and she does
then ideas man
so I know man I know the look you know
saying you know the look she could be
watching TV up close as soon as I
command so just go like that and look at
my hand and look at me and look back in
the TV it'll say no but she don't need a
wink is as good as a nut to a blind
though I see understand I know because I
knew yeah that's how I used to go to my
mother's bar that's how it starts mom
why don't three guys at one time go to
the bathroom and then she would tell
them the next day guys be careful around
to see why he's a little cop you know
and said I would cause a little car I
would go back to my mom and go mom I was
talking to Helio and he had rings around
his nose and my mama could know he was
probably he had a book or something
the next day I would hear my mom hey
tell Helio not the [ __ ] do blow felt
like the Coco
does he watches he's like a little
[ __ ] cop Oh in those days I used to
be a tortured shame I didn't like my
number one I liked as a kid not to smoke
but I liked it because my favorite
person in the world that was
his only vice and he had such it nobody
had a better time smoking pot than the
guy who baptized me in the church
there's nobody I've never seen anything
like that if I had a videotape of him
rollin smoking it and then his attitude
ten minutes later everybody would smoke
pot I never saw anything like that he's
the main reason that I thought in my
head it was okay to smoke pot because he
wasn't a boozer he sold drugs I think I
was too young but right after my dad
died he picked me up every Saturday and
take me to the movies on a musing upon
him he was a real godfather I mean he
was committed to it yeah and then he
would go on these little prison things
and my mama taught me he's in California
in Miami they would get out there to
start the same relationship again once
but two or three years but when I was
about five but sexy with taking all
those James Bond movies Her Majesty's
Secret Service and really [ __ ] mr.
Fujie died yes did you see that mr.
Fujie died that was a little bad the
scenes I've ever seen well he was
throwing a hat wait pull up mr. Fuji mr.
Fuji that's one of the greatest scenes
oh and then they gave him a Kaufman the
game well that was a child they gave him
up formula 44 commercial and he'd be
coughing he'd break up the whole house
karate chop it and then they would stop
it by yielding formula 44 really yeah
well for Villa 40 Prime member that come
on now what the [ __ ] he didn't put put
it mr. Fujie formula 44 I'm coming at
you [ __ ] heavy duty if you
don't know a formula 44 is oh I thought
you turned about James Bond mr. Fuji
yeah same mr. [ __ ] Fuji now yes those
are different mr. Fuji's no there was a
Fuji that was a wrestler then there was
the Japanese Fuji that proved the
[ __ ] hat around that's what I'm
talking yeah same dude this guy got a
commercial years later you got so much
notoriety from go to mr. Fuji what are
you doing mr. Fuji for your [ __ ] up or
you have a life in in there you have
like a tilde sorry that's a comma
I just put there you go put a hyphen in
now mr. fry I said that's for Fuji I
don't think they have the commercial no
show me something a mr. foo mr. Fuji
James Bond Goldfinger yeah that's a
Goldfinger why are you putting a comma
in there that's how you do it no you
know okay start from scratch give
everything a capital you see that mister
give down the capital over there you go
to college for four [ __ ] mr. Fuji
gets a capital F to Fuji gets a capital
his whole family with monotonous acne
and you don't want to give me the
respect II [ __ ] desert okay now our
race James Bond all right just put mr.
Fuji Goldfinger try that can we [ __ ]
do that no no no give me a space mr.
Fuji Goldfinger with a [ __ ] capital G
[ __ ]
it's a movie with their every request
respect I'm telling you it's too
different mr. Fuji's I'm telling you
this has to be the [ __ ] one leave how
long did job look at this [ __ ] oh yeah
you're right it's not mr. Fuji it's odd
job oh [ __ ] him he's [ __ ] yeah that is
two different Asian guys ya know I don't
know about this [ __ ] yeah something
about the Japanese guy we click our job
fight though I'm kind of interested
which is darling I don't want to see our
job fine I want to see do not look at
this [ __ ] throws his hat dude he was the
best in you know we gotta do Bert
Kreischer was that other crisis
bartending how many [ __ ] people with
the boss I did I did fifty percent
really that's I didn't go because it was
my dream I got a job and they said do
you know how to bartend I said yeah they
go well do you know how to make a [ __ ]
martini dry and I go now
all right listen we're gonna pay go
there for two weeks from 6:00 to 9:00
once they certify you we could put you
in bank and see from making team bucks
and now it's 1984 18 bucks an hour plus
the [ __ ] bank with tip before I was
wasn't bad so they paid the [ __ ] two
bills so I went to bartending school and
that's so funny every time I go that
7-eleven there's a bartending school
right next to it
really yeah right Mike damn I'm not the
high super bank at Burbank Boulevard
you see Burbank Burbank in sand and was
it
Colfax nobody [ __ ] far I went like I
was this is how much of a nerd I was my
me my best friend from high school went
as like the freshman year summer of
college what most good to going on like
Spring Break we went to bartending
school just go to the cocktail did you
want to miss meet girls no no we I
thought we were like I was already a
server so I thought I was gonna become a
bartender but then they don't hire
bartenders just straight out you need to
like work your way up so it was
worthless going to the school so ya know
didn't and they didn't even have real
alcohol in is like color water it was
terrible
like that's what I did for a week or two
weeks I did it for two weeks so there
was pretty legit like they had booze
there and three nights of the week
people came in there for cheap drinks
that's when you know you're lucky yeah
when you're gonna our bartender school
oh yes this was I mean go get drunk get
bartending go to school and drink the
mistakes and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hilarious
and I'll never forget I study not the
three nice you like this is pretty much
a joke like you know they start from
scratch this is how you wash a glass
this is how you put ice cubes in a glass
the temperature and the water I already
knew all those things from my mother's
bar I just wanted to learn how to make
those high-end
rusty nails that's what that's what they
wanted so I sat it out till that and I
put up with the [ __ ] but there was
one dude who went in there and ran from
the jump he thought he was cocktail but
this was way before the [ __ ] movie
cocktail came out and he was a black
dude excuse me with an afro I'll never
forget this I don't know what his name
was I'm sorry and he was throwing the
bottles and they told you before class
every time he broke a bottle it was 15
bucks
and [ __ ] this guy so what they would
do is they from 6:00 to 9:00 you would
go in there and people creepy people go
in there and drink at this bartending
school how great is that oh my god they
were creepy as [ __ ] and they were drunk
already and they would just get like
Alabama slam is for $1 or who believed a
hound or a dollar and [ __ ] like that you
know but I'll never forget this black
dude one night started throwing bottles
up and he had three of them and all
three of them broke yeah yeah that's 45
bucks it's the only way you're getting
your diploma because cuz you need to get
your diploma money Friday and it was a
violation if he's got like three
violations he got three violations all
at one shot but here's the funny thing
yeah so I went to one of the better ones
I went to one of the better ones so at
this place the one guarantee they made
you was a life clam placement American
bartending Institute so I go to San
Francisco now I went to this bar to the
school February of 83 by February 5
bartending was out of my system I was a
full time criminal yeah and I'm in San
Francisco and I'm trying to get my life
together but I'm really just looking for
a school and I'm walking down the big
Street and what do I see in San
Francisco but American Bar Tennis Hall
let me roll upstairs Rob stairs there's
two [ __ ] dudes that it was like drug
dealers this cameras on Mike I know my
name is Joey Diaz I went to American Bar
through the school in New York City they
said I had a lifetime place and the guy
goes you're absolutely you're right yeah
let me call over there when did you
graduate I go February 3 got picked up
the phone at the time
give me a minute there was no computers
in those days guys I got a guy yeah you
had a call and then they put yet a check
the file you know yeah and they checked
out back on the phone yeah graduated did
great you know no complaints he he was
placed right away never a complaint ok
we'll get you a job with they sent me to
this Mexican place it was weird first
they sent me through an Italian place
and they wanted me to be there at 9:30
but you know me
I gotta go 8:40 yeah I walk in there and
they're 40 and they went somewhere and
left the safe open in the back you know
I'm walking through hello hello hello
like Johnny angel first day in this open
save your first day I open the door and
the [ __ ] two things on the trays it
has the bags deposit bags they just
started putting bags there was the
change I put so much change on this that
the jacket I had to have a suit jacket
was hanging off me like a scarecrow I
get out of there I get on the bus with
my girlfriend sighs go back to like the
job no no no no there's no reason to
fill out application
it's like a toga it's like it--okay
Quigley once somebody [ __ ] in the ends
there's no more dinners gonna be it once
somebody taps that muffler ain't staking
out for dinner no one over from now on
you get Subway sandwich a half so I got
this [ __ ] job I didn't I didn't get
the job at didn't even leave an
application like two days later they
called the hotel a lot of time I was
staying at the Virginia hotel they
called the whole town man asked me Joey
did you go for an interview and I go no
I fell asleep I'm sorry guys and they go
well somebody showed up and robbed the
place
are you sure it wasn't you and I go dumb
wasn't me and then nobody seen the guy
he was like a [ __ ] ghost so I'm just
double-checking that you you know it was
funny yeah like you're gonna go yeah
that was me
oh it was hysterical yeah and then they
sent me for another job at a Mexican
place and two guys had an interview week
but the second I came over he goes is
that really your name Jose Diaz you
really from Cuba yeah come away
he asked me ten questions look he was my
name is Jose Diaz nothing family's Cuban
so we sat there for two hours he bought
me lunch really we were related in some
sort of crazy [ __ ] way
shut up like second cousins he called
Cuba on the spot I think he was like
we'll find we'll get to the bottom of
this right now we looked the song the
same it's like we were cousins or
something like that we got the same
[ __ ] town so he got me a job at a
place called rocket Robbins on the
Haight Ashbury he goes I can't hire you
here if you want to wait a month I got
I'll give you a full-time job
yeah I'll give you a barback job I don't
wanna go [ __ ] bar back so he got me a
job at Rock'em Robbins on Haight Ashbury
that's been closed you don't even know
it so it was a great little bar over
there wow I thought you was red Robins
the purpose [ __ ] no this place had all
Cadillac on the wall there front ends of
Cadillacs yeah and when the DJ were put
certain music on the Cadillac lights
were going and [ __ ] tourists would go
crazy long [ __ ] time ago I was a
doorman on Mondays in the bartender
Thursday how many what states have you
lived in New Jersey in Aspen Colorado
Boulder Colorado Seattle Washington Los
Angeles California that's it never lived
there well on the road there yeah I just
haven't lived that many place I lived it
oh yeah I guess not I've lived in Tampa
Tallahassee New York LA that's it
how you feelin Lee you getting spots oh
yeah I can tell you getting a little
spotty [ __ ] how you feelin you're
rocking back and forth I'm good I can't
tell if I'm hot or if I'm freaking from
really high it won't put some music on
absolutely like Pink Floyd's run this
mother [ __ ] out lee-sia oh yeah nice
time just because this is a birthday
gift yeah this was a you got a nice
little time together I could tell that
you came back with refurbished looking
and shade
ready to rock this week it was uh yeah
I'm just I think we have a good time
just being together it's uh I was single
for like three or four years I think in
between college and coming out and I got
a terrible girlfriend who was just like
the worst and not everything like I'm
I'm not gonna say everything's perfect
like nothing know what nothing's ever
perfect but you and I were talking this
is perfect that as it's gonna be and
it's gonna be this is nobody's [ __ ]
perfect
no bleak nobody might meet some
match.com no one's perfect and that
really lasts for [ __ ] that without
right that's a that's a and you were
saying to me like don't leave early on
throw I was like but you know what man
we have a loan to take you three three
and a half hours so yeah but you know
what we have fun like what a like I was
thinking about it like yeah I could have
done a little bit I could have send a
couple emails but I made her happy and
we had we had fun listening to music I
don't it's uh you say I love you oh yeah
it's been over three years
so that's you're gonna give her pregnant
let's hope not for a while why hold you
28 oh you're a baby how is she
she's 26 oh yeah she trying to talk to
him from a living standpoint like I I do
it I did this mental survey yeah you
know we as men you talk to other guys
you're told not to me but you talk to
the guys you with the high school with
and maybe one of them marry the Chilean
and you know how it is and you take a
mental [ __ ] survey and I look at my
life and one of the one of the best
things I did at 25 was meet the girl
that I had jackie with
but at the same time it was one of the
worst things cuz looking back I wasn't
ready for a relationship with 25 minutes
you know were you oh no David I mean
looking back 25 and I know you had
girlfriends I'm not saying that you at
25 every guy in this room had a
girlfriend but think how it ended think
of how it went
think of how they pushed your buttons
you didn't end up with them cuz nobody
in this room got married at 26 or 27 we
all maybe I made a mistake and even
shacked up on one for years I wanted to
live like Charles Bronson I never
thought I would have lived with a
[ __ ] woman ever like when I was 21 if
you asked me when I live with a woman I
look at you and go not oh in a million
[ __ ] years you know it's crazy though
is that now you can see how those women
live their lives you can see them online
and like one of the girls is taking
planes down to Guatemala to help orphans
for her church she's very very Christian
I'm like oh thank God I didn't end up
with that and then another one is
posting like like inspirational but
weird conservative inspirational female
statements and you're just like like I'm
like [ __ ] that was the one like and then
I look at Leanne and I go oh I'm so glad
yeah I ended up with that [ __ ] chick
oh oh so far ahead so great listener
from the church I said something on a
periscope and he sent some stuff to Lee
and it was an old girlfriend of mine and
I had just said her name
and it's my XY or the [ __ ] bike yeah
and I clicked on the Facebook page and
it was horrific
oh I mean she hasn't changed I mean if
she didn't gain a pound she's doing
pretty good money girl
well it just [ __ ] hit me like a ton
of bricks I wasn't even married to her
when I saw her it reminded me how much I
didn't want to be with her when we got
separated it was just the only reason
why I continued talking to her was
because of a [ __ ] child you know
saying yeah so it was just kind of weird
so I know how that hit you I was with a
chick I was with a chick for uh five
years in college then I thought I was
gonna marry her totally thought I was
gonna marry and she ended up [ __ ] my
best friend and giving me the clap and I
was [ __ ] heartbroken that's a tough
one oh do you take that one on the chin
looking at it coming at you that's five
years of drinking trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] you did or 20d but the
[ __ ] when he were a young man that's
[ __ ] heavy
I slept with two girls Joey that's up
with two girls that's it warm protection
totally for one of them and just didn't
wear protection for the one that I dated
for five years because I was like mom
were in love that we wouldn't cheat on
each other got the clap and it was
[ __ ] brutal I told her during this
time I came back from Russia I told her
I had met the guys from the state
remember the state the state on MTV
Michael Wayans and Michael Ian Black
I wasn't watching TV this and so I met
them in Greece and David Wain had said
to me about being a comic and I was like
oh my god the seed my head and in Greece
I decided I kind of want to be a comic
then you know I come home I tell her in
confidence I think I want to be a
comedian this is before I think she told
me she had [ __ ] my best friend I said
lay in her bed for the Miami Florida
game and I was like I think I want to be
a comic she was like oh honey you're an
idiot like you're not fun
you're not like smart funny comedians
are smart funny you're stupid funny like
you'll never be a comedian and she
wanted to be an actress and I remember
being like I'll never tell a [ __ ] soul
my secrets ever and then I told her only
stone people I wanted to be a comic and
I ended up now obviously becoming a
comic and I've been doing it for I was
18 17 years but the interesting thing is
she's trying to be be off like a
Broadway actress she's been trying to be
an actress since she graduated college
she has had no success like none like
just off Broadway [ __ ] I look back and I
think had I not dated the one girl
Kristin who that was the next girl after
that was just kind of oblivious to the
way the world worked and just was like
you can do anything you want to do she
still posts inspirational feminist
conservative feminist posts
had I not dated her I don't know if I
would ever had the balls to do it and I
had I stuck with that chick I probably
would have ended up the same failure she
is and you just think about all these
little [ __ ] things and like I
remember thinking I got her pregnant at
one point and thinking oh this is this
is what the universe wants and then
you're like oh [ __ ] this the universe
doesn't want any of this [ __ ] the
universe and then and then I remember
being alone in New York being like oh
the universe wants me to be alone right
now the universe wanted me to be be
stricken of all these female opinions
and form my own about life those are the
best times in the world I like I look
back I'm like I'm so glad for all the
[ __ ] like you know not to bring a full
circle but you know this tour was gonna
be a big deal for I think both of us
would be a lot of fun a little feather
in the cap and a little bit of money and
a lot of fun but then when it went away
I went I saw it as like the universe
going like hey man you're renovating
your house you should be here with your
family and experience this change at the
time same time they experienced it I
have a certain blessing on me it's been
like that for years if it's gonna happen
yeah and if it doesn't happen something
happened that didn't want you to happen
the hands like that three years from now
you'll look and go who that's why I
didn't get that look the movie [ __ ]
bombed anyway here I was sick to my
stomach over the holidays because I lost
my powers yeah cuz you auditioned
December 18th then they tell you they
gonna tell you January 8th and also you
gotta sit through the [ __ ] holidays
thinking did you get it what did you say
in the audition what did they say to you
did they make you a hint did they say
something what's up see like that's like
that's hard for me oh you guys had this
tour canceled on you there's nothing you
can do about it mmm-hmm for me like
that's like okay cool I feel bad for the
people people tweeted me did not know
Atlanta was canceled did you know that
yeah I got pictures of people with
tickets tickets and all that [ __ ] so I
felt very bad but at the same time I
can't a fella relieved guys I kind of
felt relieved I'm not gonna lie to you
if it's meant to be it's meant to
[ __ ] let me chase I'm meant to be let
me tell you something I'm gonna use City
I get on the 405 and I take the train
tips Altman and Mister 735 I cancel that
way yes yeah that's a sign telling me
you know what it's blocked think I'm
hoping it in four hours you ain't go
around and reschedule your flight
whatever but this was something telling
you you don't need to go you turn around
I do that with I did it with when you
get to an airport and like if you rush
you can get it I go no no no what if I
don't
yeah life life knows how to throw you
different [ __ ] curveballs and they
give you little messages to rot it don't
give you life gave Lee a [ __ ] message
Saturday night Friday night he went down
there to jump up and down he jumped up
and down three times he said am I
[ __ ] [ __ ] well look at these
[ __ ] people with gloves on and this
is not I still listen I love Black
Sabbath I listen to something from Black
Sabbath every day they're gonna be here
a month from tonight tomorrow night
really yeah at the Hollywood Bowl you
and I both know on paper it's a great
[ __ ] show we need to do some
chocolate mushrooms and smoke some dope
and really
good show guys if you want to lie to you
and tell you I'll meet you at the
Hollywood Bowl if you won I can lie to
you I'll meet you don't count on me
I love Black Sabbath whatever the final
tour I know they're never gonna perform
again neither was [ __ ] the Monkees
and they always find the way you know
saying he's always gonna quit then they
don't quit who feels like an [ __ ]
you because you went to the last [ __ ]
thought yeah and then you go to the last
last tour then the last laugh last tour
when they're you know it's just so I
want to go I mean this is it
yeah but I can't imagine myself there
for two hours jumping up and down and
then driving up a Hollywood ball parking
lot down on [ __ ] Island and [ __ ]
Franklin and trying to get on Cahuenga
before the rest of the [ __ ] Mokes
because I wait for that encore and I
start walking up for no help no what if
what if what if what if an agent called
you one was like Joey here's the deal
you let your backstage passes it's all
your run do whatever you want back there
we got you a box seat up front you go if
an agent calls me and says they have
backstage passes for Ozzy Osbourne and
Black Sabbath and I can meet them yeah
I'm going but I only hang out to 15
minutes to watch the whole show I would
destroy my insides I think really I
don't know why do you put me through
these [ __ ] jeopardy question what if
okay what did they say well it wouldn't
it be nice if there like a lone nice
afterparty good food backstage hang out
with the band if somebody who was my
friend Langley or you or Damon with that
I'd feel more comfortable
I wouldn't feel like an [ __ ] I'm just
completely let's let's 20 years ago 30
years ago I wanted to kill myself in a
Black Sabbath concert like I was gonna
shoot myself in the head and it allows
the guys of all gods that a bunch of us
were like listen let's just take those
[ __ ] that had aspirins remember one
people poisoning people and aspirins I
love oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I loved Ozzy
Osbourne I like everything Black Sabbath
stood for I was there since [ __ ]
since sabotage the first time I saw that
album cover I was like wait a second
what the [ __ ] is that
i'ma bringing home and putting an island
known oh my god I have to smoke pot
don't understand this yeah
like I have to get high to figure out
what the [ __ ] they're saying and that's
what made me get high that might not
bother getting high cutting up the weed
and he would smoke and then he would
giggle for hours it's the best polled
schoolin old Aleve throw away the half
the joint and that's it he would drive
me back to my mother's and he would tell
me don't tell your mother about me
smoking pot what's the best part is my
balls and giggling and I wouldn't tell
my mother and with my mother smoke pot
in front of me I wouldn't tell him so I
was living like a double [ __ ] ages
let me give a shout out to the sponsors
we get the [ __ ] out of here we get down
the hill here almost always my favorite
Chris over dot sue Sarah the ultimate
natural [ __ ] fire happen that's what
these [ __ ] do whether it's the
hem tiles the real dope D pants they got
a rewards program they got a beautiful
rash guards I mean listen their bag is
one of the best bags I've ever had all
together period I had that Nike bag
three months it started breaking [ __ ]
apart that little rubber Chinese bag
they charge you $30 for this [ __ ] bag
is so durable listen I already told you
how many things I have in the pockets I
even found more [ __ ] pockets down
below the other day for like mouthpieces
and wallets this doctor shower bag the
heavy-duty the the head bag
check it out online go to Diaz get calm
right now and look at the great
selection with the gear the Geezer
badass key the [ __ ] real dope gear
pants a tremendous look at the fanny
pack which is tremendous I mean listen I
will guarantee every product there this
partner might deal with you I'll tell
you what I'll do go to Diaz gear.com
right now look at the great selection of
her products they have you see something
you're like go in the box and press in
Joey damn Jay Oh ey
and get five percent off your order I
loved that too sorry alright so do me a
favor go to diaz gear.com and take a
look at that great selection of hemp
products
you see something you like again what
are they Presley Joey
boom number two on accom baddest
[ __ ] ever you want to do
something healthy for yourself get a jar
the [ __ ] mixed greens the first
two dumps you take you see your soul you
understand me
that's how healthy [ __ ] out it is you
got the alpha brain
you got the shroom tech you have the
hemp force protein shake I mean listen
it never [ __ ] ends do me a favor I
can't do any deals for you in the cattle
bowels of the boss but as far as
supplements
I got you [ __ ] go to the box and
press in church boom CH you are CH and
get 10% off your order to live it
straight to your [ __ ] door Bert
Kreischer one of your dates
um Toledo September 9th through 11th
your beautiful I gotta come and love you
[ __ ] thank you very much for
checking in have a great week have a
great Monday get ready for Labor Day
we'll be back Wednesday you [ __ ]
I love you don't forget Wednesday night
the ice house next Thursday flappers -
no expectations tour stay black
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Cisco
[Music]
see don't make it up
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]